PROFESSOR: Ladies and
gentlemen, our speaker
this afternoon is Professor
Morris Halle, an Institute
professor who has been
associated with linguistics,
now linguistics and
philosophy, and with RLE.
He joined RLE, as I did when
Jerry Wiesner was directing it,
1951.
So I've known Morris since
somewhat before that.
Over all of the years, I
think my favorite quotation
came from when he received
the Killian Award,
and talked about how he
had become a linguist,
and said that in his
childhood in Latvia,
he grew up in a household in
which all the adults spoke
different-- every adult
had a different language.
And he knew, he induced, being
an intelligent fellow, induced
from his surroundings
that when you grew up
you got your own language.
And indeed it
happened, but he never
guessed that his was
going to be English.
He's going to talk to us on
a representation of words
and memory.
HALLE: You need a
handout anybody here
you can't follow this without--
this speech without a handout.
Where's my-- Yeah,
that's better.
The light is so strong.
In speaking, as well as in
listening to speech of others.
we have the very clear
and distinct impression
that all utterances are
composed of discrete words.
Many people are quite surprised
when it's pointed out to them
that utterances are
quasi-continuous acoustically,
and normally contain no
pauses separating one
word from the next, the next.
[LAUGHS]
And this impression of speaking
and hearing discrete words
in the continuous
speech signal is not
lost, even by the most
experienced speech researchers,
who are completely aware that
utterances are not acoustically
segmented into words.
Now there's more to it.
When I produce the
English utterance,
a dog never plays
when he's alone,
everyone in this room cannot
only repeat it, but when I ask,
can easily establish that the
utterances consisted of eight
words, a dog never
plays when he is alone.
On the other hand, when
I produce the utterance
[NON-ENGLISH PHRASE],,
everyone in this room,
most people in this audience
will have difficulty
and repeating what I said and
will find it almost impossible
to determine how many words this
utterance was composed of, yet
you heard it just as clearly
as the other utterance I made.
Well, there's of
course no mystery
about the result of
this little experiment.
The second utterance
was in Czech, a language
that I suppose not many
people in this room command.
And since they did not
know Czech, they couldn't--
they didn't know the words--
since they don't know Czech,
they don't know
the words of Czech,
and knowledge of a
language, of course,
crucial to all
aspects of speech.
Our experiment also
brings out the fact
that an essential aspect of
the knowledge of language
is the knowledge of your words.
Now, most people think that
that's all, but it's not true.
But I will not enlighten
you on that topic.
I will limit--
I will perhaps reinforce
the incorrect impression
that many of you may have,
that knowing the words is all.
It's a large part of what you
have to do, but it isn't all.
Now, this totally unsurprising
proposition however,
has a number of corollaries
that provide helpful hints
about the nature of
language perhaps the most
important of these for our topic
is that we are not born knowing
the words of our language.
The words we know we have
learned from our parents,
from other people, from
books or other media,
so what does it
mean to know a word?
When we learn or
come to know a word,
we store in our
memory information
of a certain kind that
enables us to use the word
and not to insist that
we ourselves produce,
and to recognize it when used
in an utterance by someone else.
The information that we
need in order to do this
is of two kinds.
On the one hand,
we need information
about the sound of the word.
Let us call this the
phonetic information.
On the other hand,
we need information
about the meaning of the word,
about its lexical category,
for example, we need
to know is it a noun
or a verb or an adjective,
it's grammatical peculiarities,
for example, is it a
strong or weak verb?
Does it form its plural with a
regular S as in cakes or keys
or with an N as in
children and oxen.
Let's call the
latter information
grammatical semantic
information.
The present talk will be limited
to the phonetic information.
I shall have nothing
to say, next to nothing
to say, about the other kind.
So if anybody wants
to talk about it,
I'm happy to answer
questions about it.
OK, so now we know
that we must store
in our memories, the phonetic
information about every word.
Now, this-- that is, we
are not born knowing it
and if you want to say
dog or cat or table
or whatever you want to
happen to want to say,
something has to be in
your memory to say it.
We very rarely make up words.
For all practical
purposes, we could
say we never make up words.
We always get them
from the outside.
Now this naturally
leads to the question
as to the form in
which this memory is
stored, the form in
which this information is
stored in our memory.
It has been assumed by most
linguists and other students
of language that the phonetic
information about each word
is stored as a sequence of
discrete units called phonemes.
As a first approximation,
we may think of the phonemes
as the units that
are represented
by the letters in
written language.
Thus the claim
that is being made
here is that speakers of
English remember the word cat
as being composed
of three phonemes,
whereas the word scat is a
sequence of four phonemes,
et cetera, et cetera.
If you reflect on it
a bit, the proposition
that the words are
composed of phonemes
is anything but self-evident.
It implies that all
speakers of all languages
store the words they know as
sequences of discrete letter
size units.
Perhaps the most dubious
implication of this proposition
is that this must be true also
very young children, say, three
or four years and
younger, for many of them
speak quite fluently.
If our claim is
correct, they must
be able not only to split
up into discrete words,
the continuous speech
that they hear,
but they must also
be able to segment
the words into phonemes.
Such children must
therefore be able to perform
sophisticated analysis
on the utterances they
hear that are beyond present day
capabilities of speech science.
Even worse, perhaps
even worse, is
that there is nothing out there
in the world that might suggest
to two-year-old, or to
anyone for that matter,
that speech consists
of words and that words
are composed of phonemes.
You know, this
discovery that the words
are composed of phonemes
underlies alphabetic writing.
And alphabetic writing wasn't
discovered till, you know,
3,000 years ago.
But human beings have
been around probably
speaking for God knows,
maybe a million years.
But anyway, it's a
relatively recent discovery
that sort of was a
conscious discovery.
Yet, as an
unconscious discovery,
if this claim is true, it
must underlie all language
at all times.
And this is rather surprising,
and from self-evident.
So how come that
somebody learns it,
since you know your mother
never tells you to study
the phonemes of your language.
And certainly mothers,
maybe now, recently,
that they become more anxious
about their children getting
into kindergarten.
But even when I
was a child, people
didn't worry too much about it.
So the question is, how
come that children even
begin to get the idea
that they have to do that.
Well, when you are faced
with unanswerable questions,
the obvious move, there
is one standard and moves
that every professor,
I mean everybody knows,
and that is to question
the presuppositions.
So instead of
answering the question,
we all say, well, what's
the presupposition
of this question?
And maybe we can then get on.
Now implicit in the subject
in this question and objection
is the assumption that
children need to learn both
that there are words
and that the words
are composed of phonemes.
Instead, we might assume
something different.
And here we follow
a line of reasoning
that I like lots of
what goes on here,
was pioneered by
Chomsky originally,
and namely that this knowledge
is hardwired into all of us
at birth.
And that the knowledge that
speech is composed of phonemes
is as much part of our
physiological makeup
as our heart or lungs and liver.
Our language has a word
for such innate knowledge.
And that's the word instinct.
And here I quote from
the Webster's third,
and it said that the instinct is
a complex and specific response
on the part of an organism
to environmental stimuli that
is largely hereditary and
unalterable, though the pattern
of behaviors through
which it is expressed
may be modified by learning,
that does not involve reason,
a learning that does
not involve reason,
and that has as its goal
the removal of attention
or excitation.
Well, I mean if you have the
instinct for chopping words
into phonemes, well,
then you do them.
There is nothing to explain.
That's the only way you
can be because that's
what it means to be,
at least in part,
be human, and have the
capacity to learn language.
So children now, if this
assumption is correct,
learn words not because
they're taught to do so,
but rather because they are
constructed from birth so as
to do this.
And part of their net
machinery consists
of the mechanisms that analyze
words into its phonemes.
And of course, we do
not know very much
about these mechanisms.
But that's the logic
of the situation.
Now, there's even some very
simple experimental evidence
showing that very young English
speaking children analyze
their words at the phonemes.
The evidence involves
the ability of children
to form plural self
nouns they know.
So in English, the plurals
are formed, as you all know,
by adding S.
Well, that's not quite correct.
If you look at
the examples in 2,
you will see that
they differ somewhat.
So, it's very clear,
if you look in,
let's say, 2C, that you don't
add just S. You add B CH.
The word beach and the
plural of that is not beach,
but it's B ches.
You add a whole syllable.
And if you looking 2B, you
don't add SS, which is, right?
But you add-- notice,
you don't say keys.
You don't say plays.
You say keyz, playz, which is--
so you add zz there.
And finally, in fact,
you do add s, just
in the case of the
examples in 2A.
All right?
So, notice that there are three
distinct plurals, not just one.
Those of you who
came in late, better
sit next to somebody
who has a handout.
I don't have any more.
Because you can't follow
this without the--
OK.
All right, so there's
three suffixes.
And you know, the children
have to know which to say.
For example, if a
child says keys.
You'll notice that
there's something
wrong with the way
the child speaks
and Mom might get anxious.
But children never do that.
They always do--
they never say--
or if a child were to say
cakus, instead of cakes,
you would notice that.
And children never do.
They know how to
say it correctly.
In fact, it turns out that
these plural suffixes are not
randomly distributed.
You don't have to learn
each word with its plural.
But there is a general rule.
And a rule is given in--
one form of the rule, we'll
be talking about this rule,
is given in 3.
Now what it says there, if the
noun ends in chuh, juh, suh,
shuh, zshuh, then
the plural is us.
OK, that's the first
part of the rule.
Second part, otherwise, if
it doesn't end in this list,
then, if it ends in kuh, puh,
tuh, fuh, thuh, then add sss.
And finally, otherwise, add zzz.
So you have like a decision
tree, you know check a list.
You understand.
OK?
Now, OK, so this is a rule.
Now the question is, do
children know this rule
or is this something that's
clever linguists invented,
you know, people who
get PhDs, from MIT?
Well, the answer is that
children know this rule.
And in fact, in
the literature is
there's an experiment
that shows it.
And that experiment is rather--
I'll tell you.
It is a rather
simple experiment.
The experimenters had
different kinds of dolls
and they gave them names.
So one doll had
the name was Clye.
And another doll was Clish.
Let's say another doll
was his name was Plick.
And now, obviously these
are not English words.
The children had never
heard these words.
The experimenters never-- so
they introduced these dolls
to the children and then
they ran the experiments.
And they were very careful never
to use plurals of these names.
And then they arranged them
in little groups in this room
where they the
test was conducted.
The children were brought in.
And the child was asked,
what's that, you pointing
at a group of dolls of
one type and a child would
say these are Clyes.
Or these are, what was it I had.
Whatever it was.
I couldn't pass
that test anyway.
But they were--
I'm too old for that.
They said the correct plural.
That is they always--
so for Clye, they said Clyes.
For Clish, they said Clishes.
And for Plick, they
said Plicks, you
know just like the way you're
supposed to say by this rule
number three.
Now notice, that they had
not heard these names before.
These names were
given right there.
That's the first time
they ever heard them.
And they had
certainly never heard
the plural of these words.
But they knew how to do that.
Now, the conclusion
is, of course,
that they knew the rule.
But knowing the rule implies
a little bit more than that.
That is, only did they know
the rule, they could apply it.
And in order to apply the rule,
of course, what they had to do
is they had to slice the word
up into the last phoneme,
and the rest, minimally.
And then, once they had
done that, then they
could pick the right
suffix, namely,
whatever it was for
each of the three sets,
just as is given in
your rule number three.
So the conclusion is
that none of the children
have knowledge of the kind
that presupposes their ability
to divide the continuous
speech signal up
into words, and the
words into phonemes,
and perform these
rather complicated,
perhaps not so
complicated, but anyway,
these tasks of
making the plural.
Now the next question
I will briefly discuss
is what are phonemes?
Now, when you study
phonemes, I've
give you a list of
phonemes in four.
Now, there's-- so puh,
buh, fuh, vuh, muh.
You know, those are the--
so pill, bill, phil, vale, mall,
or something like that, these
are the and similar
to duh and so on.
Now, when we pronounce these--
as you study these
things, you'll
notice something that when
you pronounce these phonemes,
all the ones that I've given
you involve complete closure.
There's closure of your
mouth, so that the air
is obstructed in its outflow.
That's very
different, let's say,
when you have other phonemes
like say, R, O, or E.
These are vowels and are quite
different from the consonants
that I've given
you, and they all
have this property
that somehow there's
an obstruction to
the flow of air.
Now what differentiates
these three groups is
the piece of machinery that you
have that obstructs the flow.
So in the first set, puh, buh,
fuh, and so on, it's the lips.
In the second set, it's the flat
part of the tongue, duh, duh.
See, it's not the lips part.
It's the flat part
of the tongue.
And in the third set, guh, guh,
it's the body of the tongue
that that stops say the airflow.
So we have three groups,
depending on the articulator
is the class--
is the technical term that
interrupts the air flow.
So that's one property, that
the air flow is interrupted,
and there's a particular
articulator that
does the interrupting.
And that's what
makes them different.
In the first line,
it says nasal.
What you notice there
is that we allow in some
sounds, the air to
flow through the nose.
We open up a side
port as it were,
which allows the air to
flow through the nose
and that excites certain
resonances in these cavities
here.
And you have these
sounds like mmm,
nnn, you know, these
so-called nasal sounds.
The rest of the sounds
are produced in such a way
that the soft
palate is raised up
and no air is allowed to
flow through the nose.
And so, we have this--
and you see, what you're
supposed to see here
is that this is a
particular gesture that
is the same in all
three types of sound.
So nuh and muh are quite
similar in that you have
a lowering of this soft palate.
But in one case you
superimpose this
on a labial stoppage of flow.
In the other case, you impose it
on a coronal stoppage of flow.
And in the third case on
a dorsal stoppage of flow.
What you see here is
that they all, they
have a sort of similar
internal structure.
Now if you look at
the non-nasal sounds,
you notice two other things.
You notice that sounds
like puh and tuh and fuh
are produced without
vocal cord vibration.
Now you can tell whether
your vocal cords vibrate.
When you say zzzz, they vibrate.
And you can feel that when you
say, ssss, they don't vibrate.
So there is another property
that this vocal cord
vibration that goes in.
And now you notice again, you
can vibrate your vocal cords
while stopping the
airflow with your lips,
or while stopping it
with your flat part
of the tongue or the
tongue body and you
can do that in different ways.
And finally, there-- and that
is represented by the minuses
and pluses in the second line.
And it says, something
happens that your glottis,
that you switch on and off and
either the vocal cords vibrate
or they don't.
And that's represented
on line two.
Now finally, the
stoppage can be complete,
as it is, let's
say in puh, or tuh,
or it can be sort of partial as
it is, in let's say, th or sss,
where air is trapped inside
your mouth, but only partially.
OK.
Now, and what you notice
here is that these
are sort of subgestures,
the closure, the lowering
of the velum, the behavior of
the vocal folds, each of these
is represented in
three variance,
in the first class, where
the major closure is made
with the lips, in
second class where it's
made with the flat
part of the tongue,
in the third part where it's
performed with the tongue body,
by raising the tongue body.
And now these subgestures,
you find in all--
each phonemes therefore is sort
of a complex of subgestures.
And the technical term
is to say that phonemes
are complexes of features.
Now, so that a
speech sound is not
something which is further
unanalyzable, but rather it's
a complex of subproperties.
So now, and perhaps the
most interesting observation
to be made is, of all
the sounds in the world,
only phonemes are
complexes of features
and only can be
analyzed into phonemes.
And they must be
So when you hear,
to ask, what does--
when you represent, let's
say a sound of the car
or a rattle in your
car, you don't have
phonemes to represent that.
I mean some kind
of rattle that--
whereas words, they
divided into phonemes.
And the phonemes are
made up of features.
That's sort of the idea.
OK.
Now this digression, this
technical digression,
was necessary to bring
out the next thing.
Now obviously, none
of you, or most of you
who has never heard of
phonemes before, now I'm
here the first to tell you.
Now what's interesting is that
we now may ask a question.
Do people who know
English do they think
about the phonemes in
terms of indivisible units
or our English speakers,
in their naive behavior,
is their behavior
properly characterized
in terms of features?
And here is an--
and we will try to show
you how that works.
Now, if the latter is
true, then the knowledge
is that the people that
know the plural rule, that
know the rule number
three, then of course, they
wouldn't have lists of phonemes.
They would have feature
lists of some sort.
That is, this
knowledge would not
be represented by
a list of phonemes.
But if phonemes are
always feature bundles,
then they would be
represented by feature vowels.
So for example, let's
now look at five,
which is a translation
of three into features.
Now notice, the first set is
the sounds suh, zjuh, suh, zuh,
chuh, juh.
Now, all these sounds are
made with the flat part
of the tongue.
They are coronal.
They have the coronal feature.
And moreover, they have
some other features
which we won't bother.
OK, so the translation of the
list, that's the list in 3A,
is, as I've given in five,
saying it's cornonal.
Does it have the feature coronal
plus some other features?
Now the second list says,
puh, tuh, kuh, fuh, thuh.
Now, those are all the
sounds and only that
are made out without
vibration of the vocal folds.
They're unvoiced.
And so the rule now has been
translated into into feature.
I mean five is just a
translation into feature terms,
of that list that I've
given you in three.
And now the question
is, in which
form do you, as a speaker of
English, know the plural rule?
Now the answer, and we'll now
run an experiment right away,
and we will see
whether it works.
OK, now the test
was suggested to me
many years ago by
at Lise Menn, who's
now a professor at the
University of Colorado.
And what the test that she
suggests was quite simple.
First of all, she
said, look, you
can ask people to make
plurals of non-English words.
So for example, if you
knew a Frenchman whose name
was de la Rue, although [? Uu ?]
doesn't exist in English,
you could ask what's the
plural of Monsieur de La
Rue and his family.
And somebody would--
So what is it?
Which one?
Well, which one, the first,
the second, or the third?
Third one OK, fine.
Good.
We're getting there.
Now.
The two lists make
different predictions
about this sound, oo.
Number three says,
regardless, of what
the sound is, if it's
not an English sound,
you have to make zzz.
That's what number three says.
But number 5 doesn't say that.
Number five says,
look at its features.
If it has the features,
then apply the rule.
OK, so now we have to
find a phoneme of English,
which not in English, but
which has appropriate features.
So that wouldn't
pick number three.
And we do have that.
And everybody knows
Johann Sebastian Bach.
Now Bach, he had many children.
And so, what's the
plural of Bach.
Number two, not number three.
OK?
Now it's clear that everybody
picks number two and not
number three.
Although chuh is not
a phoneme of English.
Therefore there
couldn't be a list.
It couldn't be
listed in anything
that's a rule of English.
And therefore, since the
action was performed here
and the test was
run here, it's clear
that somehow or other people
know something about features.
Maybe they had never
heard about it.
But then you know
a lot of things
you haven't heard about that
play a real role in life.
OK.
So we have now established
that phonemes are actually
bundles of features.
And that speakers have
knowledge in a very strong sense
of these features.
They may not have any
way of talking about it.
But then we don't have any way
of talking about how we walk.
We don't know how
we balance ourselves
so that we don't fall down.
But we know how to do that even
though we can't talk about it.
OK.
So these are features.
I mean that phoneme is
a bundle of features.
And a word, now, we
can now say something
about the way the word
is represented in memory,
namely be represented by a
matrix, where each column will
represent a column of features.
And there will be
as many phonemes--
each phoneme will be
a column of features.
And there'll be as many phonemes
in the word as there are--
as many columns as there
are phonemes in the word.
So that's now the
claim that we're
going to make about the
representation of words
in memory.
Now we want to go
on a little bit
and say perhaps a
little bit more.
Now, notice that the
features are, in one sense,
they are instructions.
They are instructions
for actions.
That is in one case,
say lower your velum.
Or close your lips.
Or they are actions that
are observable actions.
Now in memory of course,
these instructions
serve to distinguish
one word from another.
So the difference between, let's
say, the word bill and the word
mill, is that in mill, we
have the instruction lower
your velum, plus nasal.
Whereas in bill,
it's minus nasal.
That is the instruction.
But in memory they serve as a
kind of a purely at diacritic
m which distinguishes
one matrix from another.
And only at some
particular point
does it eventuate in action.
Now interestingly,
when you hear a signal,
you therefore have
to analyze the signal
in terms of these
actions in order
to pick the word out of your
memory if the story is correct.
I mean, the matrices
are matrices
in terms of actions
of particular pieces
of the machinery here.
Now so what this sort of
presupposes or implies
is that there is a kind of
a primacy of the gymnastics
that's going on over the
sound that's out there.
That is, you analyze a sound
in terms of the gymnastics
in order to figure
out which word did he
say in order for me to
understand that person whose
speech I'm now understanding?
Now this may sound
rather surprising.
Now some researchers
have questioned
the need for the
translation from acoustics
into articulations.
Articulations is
this gymnastics.
And I've proposed instead
that features in memory
are directly related
to properties
in the acoustic signal, rather
than being indirectly related
to properties in
the [INAUDIBLE]..
It is therefore
necessary at this point
to review the
evidence that supports
the alternative view that--
for me, since I
have proposed that,
that the acoustic signal
is not directly related
to the specific acoustic
properties and in the signal,
but rather that
this relationship is
indirect mediated.
Now this view, by the way,
has a name in the literature.
And it's called
the motor theory.
And it has been
championed for a long time
by Alan Liberman of
Haskins Laboratory
and a number of other
people that you may know.
Now I will give a
little bit of evidence
why I think this
is so, that there's
a primacy of the
articulation over the sound.
And the first
evidence is, when you
ask speakers of any
language to say a word,
so you make a nonsense
word like soup, let's say,
just made up some word.
And you ask somebody to say
it, without even in the dark,
so they can't see or
you play a record,
so they can't see what
you do when you say,
please repeat this word, the
actions that they perform
will be enormously uniform.
They may not 100%.
But the uniformity is
enormously surprising.
So when they hear
that word they will
start by raising the
flat part of the tongue
against the roof of the mouth.
And around their
lips, and then they
raise the body of the tongue.
The actions are executed
always the same.
There will never be an
attempt to mimic the sound
by putting your
fingers in your mouth
or doing something desperate.
You know, they will
always be the uniform.
And this is universal.
I mean there is no instruction,
no teaching, that happens
when you make such a request.
And so it's very it's not
only in English speaking,
when you ask somebody who never
spoke and never heard English,
tell them to
pronounce this sound
and there will be an
enormous uniformity.
And the uniformity
will be in terms
of is this execution of
this particular action.
Now notice, when you ask
people to produce a sound,
you make, and you
make some odd sound.
And say, well, see
what you can do.
And you know, like scratching
two pieces of metal plates
and reproduce this sound.
And people get very lost.
They're very flustered.
We have this built in.
Certain sounds, we analyze
into articulatory gestures,
namely features.
And those we then produce.
And then others we do
all kinds of wild things.
Another bit of evidence is the
so-called McGurk experiment
as some of you may know.
Now the McGurk
experiment consisted
of the following
rather surprising test.
People heard a tape
and shown a tape
in a video where somebody says,
da, da, da, da, da, da, da.
At a particular point, the
audio portion remains the same,
but the video portion changes to
somebody saying, like this, you
know, Saying doo, doo,
doo, doo essentially,
although the audio portion
continues saying da, da, da.
And the impression
that people have
is that the person switched.
And that he is now
saying doo, doo.
And you can actually
turn off the video
and they hear the
da, da, ad again.
And you turn the video up,
and it's serving the illusion.
And the illusion
simply shows you
that are the
articulatory information,
once you receive this
articulatory cue,
I mean, so overwhelming,
that you think that you
hear something different.
So here's another bit of
some of kind of evidence
that suggests that.
Now the third is what
happens in language.
And thus is this my last point
I will take about 10 minutes
to make it.
And that is that, in
addition to making plurals,
there are other kind
of rules in language.
And I'll begin by one.
And these rules as you will
see, always affect features.
They always affect one
or two features as you
will see in just a moment.
So take for example,
the words in six.
Now notice, when we say,
take a word like leaf.
Now the plural of leaf
happens not to be leafs,
but it's leaves.
We say chief, chiefs.
But leaf, leaves.
OK.
Now the same thing,
we'll take house.
The plural of house
is not houses.
That would be the plural
of Hermans and his family.
But it would be it's houses.
I mean so what happens
is that in the plural,
we change the shape of the stem.
The noun in the plural
has a different sound
than in the singular.
So house in the plural
in the singular.
But houzz in the plural.
How we don't in--
not reflected in the spelling.
But notice for f and
v we reflect that even
in the spelling.
So we say leaf, but
the plural is leaves
and we write a different
letter to reflect that.
But for house we don't bother.
We don't write z there.
There's a small number
of English words
which have this property.
And In order to speak English
correctly, you have to do that.
If you said, leafs,
somebody would correct you.
That's not correct.
I mean you so there is
this kind of small rule.
And we have a rule, which
I've written in number seven.
And what the rule
says is that if you
have a sound such as plus
continuant means ffss,
it is that kind of sound,
which has incomplete blockage
of the flow.
This sound in the
plural becomes voiced.
It changes its composition
so that instead
of being produced without
vocal cord vibration,
it's now produced with
vocal cord vibration.
So there is such-- and that's
part of knowing English.
OK, now, interestingly,
there's other things
that affect voicing in English.
So let's take the
suffix that's spelled
th, which you find on the one
hand in the ordinal numbers,
so twelfths.
Twelfths.
Twelve, but twelfths.
Say, now, or, five,
and you say fifths.
It's not five, but fifth.
So there's, the vuh becomes
fuh, which in speech term,
means it becomes voiceless.
And notice the same
thing happens in the--
when the th is used to make
a noun from an adjective.
So we say swide
And we say widths.
duh, but widths Or we say,
or broad, we say breadths.
OK I mean there
other such examples.
All right?
Now what's interesting
is that here again, we
have, in terms of
features, what we would say
is that this consonant becomes
minus voice before the suffix
th.
You this like this
is a suffix th.
But here it's sort of
wrong to put it that way.
Because really what's going
on here is not this th
is itself minus voice.
You know, when we had the--
I've written here without
the feature composition.
But th itself, th,
is a voiceless.
So now what's going on here is
that the feature minus voice,
is sort of spread onto
the preceding sound.
It's being anticipated,
as it were.
See, it's not just any
change that's going on here.
It isn't as though you
know, this constant becomes
the nasal or some crazy change.
The change here
is really a change
of a feature spreading from
one phoneme onto the other.
And if what you
have here is a kind
of an anticipation
of voicelessness.
You know that this is
going to be voiceless.
So therefore, you
anticipate it already.
But now let's go back to
the English plural rule.
Notice what we had there was,
we had, we said, well, we get,
if it's minus voice.
then it becomes sss,
otherwise it's zzz.
Remember that's what rule
five said, the last part.
But again, what
you have here, see,
is a spreading in the
opposite direction.
That is, the spreading it
goes from the end of the stem
onto the suffix, that
is the suffix was zz
or the basic suffix is zz.
But if it follows a
voiceless consonant,
then the voicing feature
now is spread onto it.
So here you have as it were, a
kind of a perseverance inertia
effect, where this
feature of the stem
is held over onto the suffix.
And I've represented these
two things in your handout
in, one is, in 10 and the
other one is in the 11.
Where I try to show
you that in one case
we have kind of an anticipation
effect, and in the other case,
we have an inertia effect.
And now again, is that I want
to go on and show you a very
surprising, unexpected effect.
Another is when we look
at the actual gesture
and it begins to make
very good sense when
we look at the
actual gesture, which
I'm going to now tell you.
OK, now how do you do--
how is voicing produced?
I mean, we vibrate
our vocal cords.
How we do that?
Well, we don't-- each vibration
isn't individually controlled.
They go much too fast.
They go several
hundred times a second.
So it has to be done
in some other way.
And the way you do it
is basically ttthpt,
like the soul.
I mean what right it's a kind of
a relaxation oscillation, where
you blow air up from the lungs.
The vocal chords sit
on top of the lungs.
They're elastic as the
pressure builds up.
The vocal chords
are shoved apart.
Then some air escapes.
The pressure drops.
The Bernoulli effect takes over.
Vocal cords close.
And you know the whole
thing starts all over again
from the beginning.
So that's the actual action.
Now Ken Stevens and I,
who, like Peter Elias and I
go back to prehistoric times,
so we some 25 years ago we
investigated the matter.
We studied this whole
question of how that works.
And one of the things
we noticed immediately,
and for this we claim no
credit, or we shouldn't claim
any credit, is that I
mean that what happens
is you stiffen the vocal cords.
As you stiffen the vocal
cords, what happens?
Now interesting, the
first thing that happens
is that the rate of
vibration will increase.
So as you make them stiffer,
the rate of vibration increases.
Now we know that we control--
what does the vocal
cord vibration reflect?
Well, when I increase
my vocal cords--
let's say when I say
a vowel, or any vowel,
and I increase the rate of
vibration of my vocal cord,
the pitch goes up.
I say, ah, oh, oh.
These are changes in
the rate of vibration
that are effective probably
by changing the stiffness
of the vocal chords.
Now, however, and here's
the more interesting fact,
when you make a
vowel sound, you're
as I indicated were,
your mouth is wide open
and no air is trapped
in your mouth.
And the pressure
inside your mouth
is roughly ambient pressure.
And so the drop from what
goes on from the lungs
into the mouth is sort
of the maximal pressure
that the difference that can be.
Now what happens when you say,
let's say, sss or the zzz?
Well when you say sss, you
trap air in your mouth.
And some pressure is built
up inside your mouth.
And therefore the drop
across the vocal folds,
assuming that the pressure in
the lungs remains the same,
is less.
So we have two cases.
In a sound like sss, we
have a small pressure drop.
And in a sound like ahh, we
have maximum pressure drop.
And now, the question
we asked, was
what happens as you change,
make the same changes
in vocal chords stiffness?
What will be the behavior
of the vocal chords?
Now we know in the case
of big pressure drop,
there will be increasing
in the rate of vibration.
But in the case of a
little pressure drop,
small pressure drop, what
happens not surprisingly, when
you think about it, is you
increase the stiffness,
the vocal chords
stopped vibrating.
Because there's just not
enough push at this point to--
the stiffness is now so
great that and the pressure
is so small that they
simply don't vibrate.
So that says that as a gesture,
the differences in pitch, that
is high pitch versus low pitch,
and voicelessness, absence
of vocal cord vibration,
and presence of vocal cord
vibration, are produced
by the same mechanism.
Right?
That is the same
articulatory mechanism
that is involved in
making changes in pitch
is present in making the
difference-- differentiating
sss from zzz from vvv and so on.
Now that's simply the
logic of the situ.
That seems to be the way it is.
Now the question is, but now
notice what's interesting
and if you look in number
in your handout under 13,
I've sort of made a
table there, and I said,
there's a large pressure drop.
And on the left, there's
a stiff vocal folds
and slack vocal folds.
And there was a large pressure
drop, higher rate of vibration
versus lower rate of vibration,
with small pressure drop,
absence of vibration,
cessation of vibration,
presence of vibration.
OK?
So but now notice acoustically,
and here is a question
that we try to raise.
What has primacy?
Is it the gymnastics
or is the sound?
OK, now notice, the
sound is very different.
I mean there is really
nothing in common
between a high pitched vowel
and a voiceless consonant
and a low pitched vowel
and a voice consonant.
So here is--
acoustically as they
should go their separate ways.
But from the point of
view of the mechanism,
they seem to be
going the same way.
But we have even, when
we have a little bit
of linguistic evidence
to show that perhaps
that's the right way to go.
And that is and this evidence
is given in these examples
from a Chinese
dialect in number 14.
Now what goes on there
is, in the Chinese words,
in many of the
Chinese languages,
they are differentiated by the
pitch contours that they have.
So they have a falling
contour or a rising contour
or an even contour.
And that makes
differences in meaning.
I mean, you know
everybody knows that.
OK, but now in this particular
dialect, which is not
the standard, I
mean we should not
the Mandarin standard
dialect or any of the--
it's a particular
[? Amoid ?] dialect.
Now what you see there is this.
That look on the
left hand column.
Now the numbers
indicate pitches.
So five is the highest
pitch and one is the lowest.
So five three is a falling pitch
and three five is a rising.
And four four is even.
But now notice, you have
these two sets of words.
And they have falling,
even, and rising.
And they come in two versions,
a high pitch version,
when the sound is tuh,
and a low pitched version
when the sound is duh.
So in T, in the word T, they
have three versions of the word
T, And you know was,
T and T and T and T.
And then they have
the same with D.
But the register in
which it happens.
So is it a high register or
a lower register if you will.
And that goes of course, with
the voicing of the proceeding
of the constant.
If you have tuh, which is the
voiceless consonant, which
is one, that you form by
stiffening your vocal folds,
you now spread the
stiffening of the vocal folds
onto the following vowel.
And therefore the pitch
of the vowel goes up.
In the other case,
you have slack
in the vocal folds-- you
have duh, with slackening
of the vocal folds,
and as a result,
you spread that over to
the vowel, and as a result,
the pitch of the vowel drops.
So in fact, the
rule, there seems
to be a rule in Chinese, which
said spread that stiffening
from the preceding consonant
onto the following vowel,
and that's it.
So the rule is really,
just exactly like the rule
that we have for
the English plural,
only in the English plural,
we spread it among consonants
and leave the vowels
alone as it were.
Whereas in Chinese, we spread
from a consonant to the vowel.
And the results are
exactly as expected.
But implicit in all this
is, that the gesture,
the articulately gymnastics,
is the primary thing.
Whereas the acoustic result is,
as it were a secondary thing.
So this brings me, I'll just
have one brief conclusion.
I'll say that I've
argued that words
are stored in memory of
sequences of discrete phonemes.
I've suggested that
phonemes are composed
of more elementary
entities, namely features.
I've attempted to give some idea
of the nature of the features.
And I've discussed
a number of factors
to suggest that a significant
part as an analogy speakers
have of their language
involves features.
I noted that because of
its great complexity,
it's implausible to assume
that the machinery involved
in the memorization
and production of words
is learned by speakers.
Instead it's more
plausible to assume
that much of the knowledge
required for speaking
is innate, hardwired
in us at birth.
And finally, I
gave some evidence
to show that the
articulately reactions
of the different features
have a more central character
to the functioning of languages
than their acoustic effects.
[APPLAUSE]
Any questions?
AUDIENCE: If English is
not your [INAUDIBLE],,
when does the hard
wiring set in?
HALLE: It's different
for different people.
You know I have a colleague,
Ken Hale, for whom he's 55,
hardwiring has yet to begin.
But for most people
it's around puberty.
Puberty, about 12, 13.
AUDIENCE: How do deaf mutes
ever learn a language?
It must be very different.
HALLE: Well, notice that
their natural language
is, of course, for gesture.
Now you see, what we speak, your
mom always tells you not to,
but most of us do.
And, the deaf you
see, they develop
language which is every
bit as complex as English.
It's not English.
I mean deaf, deaf mutes
do not just sign words.
I mean, they say English
words in the order in which
the English syntax puts them.
They have a sign
language, which--
AUDIENCE: Their memory must
work quite differently.
HALLE: No, their memory
is in terms of gestures.
And they happen to have
gestures of the upper body
and the hands,
rather than gestures
of the lips and
those articulators
that we use of those
of us who can hear.
And it's clearly--
and as you well know,
that these children,
for example,
deaf children of parents who
are not deaf, they learn sign
and they learn sign correctly,
although the parents very often
don't know how to
sign correctly.
Because a lot of it is
really innate in them.
And we have these both
parallel channels,
of which, for obvious
energetic reasons,
the spoken, the one
that we use for speaking
is to be preferred,
because you're
moving much smaller masses.
You know, when you move
your arms and your body,
I mean, you're
really moving pounds.
You know, whereas
when you move this,
you just move a few grams.
And therefore it's
much more efficient
from that point of view.
So that's the preferred one.
But sign languages
have existed and exist
there's just every bit as
complicated as other languages.
Louis.
AUDIENCE: The
storing of a language
involves many thousands of
words and [INAUDIBLE] and so on.
And it's tempting
at least to, ask,
it is a memory in terms
of all these words, which
is very large, or is it in
terms of features or whatever,
and features and rules,
which can combine
things to make the words.
What's know about this?
Or what's speculated?
HALLE: What I showed you that
the representation would have
to be in terms of some feature.
I mean we're extremely
gifted, enormously
gifted for memorizing
enormous numbers of words.
You know, the average
child aged six,
knows something like I
don't know 30,000 words.
And that's an enormous number.
You know, when you think that, I
mean there's stages in children
or ever they learn something
like a word an hour,
a new word an hour.
Those of you who've taken
language courses and have
had to memorize the words.
Well, we all know what a
horrible, difficult task
that is.
And so we're very capable,
I mean, naturally,
very gifted at memorizing
thousands and thousands
of words at a young age.
And the rules of language,
like those that I showed you,
are very obviously
in terms of features.
A feature changes because
you spread this feature
onto some adjacent
phoneme, as I tried
to show you or things like
that, that what goes on.
Sir.
AUDIENCE: You make
a good case for how
[INAUDIBLE] mechanical
question or gymnastic question.
How do you explain roof, roofs,
and hoof, hooves, or the fact
that we use a different
plural for the word loaf,
depending on its meaning?
HALLE: Yeah.
You didn't get the handout.
In number seven, I said
that, or number six,
I forget now what number it was.
Number seven, I said
that there's a list.
I said notice,
applies only to leaf.
There's about 30 words,
where this rule applies.
And it's part of,
you have to memorize.
I mean a large part of
English is memorization.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
HALLE: Child will
probably, notice,
children will make mistakes.
And the mistakes, so for
example, you probably
if you've seen children
will say mouses.
Now notice, they never heard
mouses, or they will hear oxes.
You know, they'll say oxes.
They never heard oxes.
Because the language around
them doesn't use that.
So is that I mean
that goes again,
to show that they know the rule.
And they've learned the rule.
And they haven't learned
the exception rule, namely
that for ox you don't
do it, you know.
So they just go by
the regular rule,
until somebody takes them
aside and says, hey, hey.
Ma'am.
AUDIENCE: In section eight,
in item eight of your list.
HALLE: What?
AUDIENCE: In your item
eight in your handout,
you talked about the
[INAUDIBLE] last consonant.
The more striking thing
there is the vowel change.
Do you have an explanation
for the vowel change?
HALLE: Yes I do, but
that's a long story.
You see me privately,
I'll tell you.
That's a long story, yeah.
It's shortening thing.
These are partly shortening
and other things too.
But that's a lie, I would
take me 10 minutes to do it.
So it's not appropriate.
AUDIENCE: You
didn't get a chance
to talk about things like
syllable structure or stress
pattern.
I assume that's because
you would group it
under your grammatical.
HALLE: No, no, .
Or This is less lesson one.
AUDIENCE: Could you comment on
the role of things like that
and the representation of words?
HALLE: Yes, I can comment.
I don't know.
I think syllable
structure and stress are--
what I believe is this.
That now, I can't
give you any evidence,
needless to say for this round.
Is that the
representation, see, I've
said that the representation
is a form of a matrix.
You know so each phoneme is a
sort of a block of features.
That's what I said.
Now, I think that the way
a proper way to think about
is even somewhat different.
Namely that this block of--
that there is a timing slot
associated with each phoneme.
And the blocks of
features are associated
with the timing slot.
And so it's possible for
example for a given phoneme
to be associated with
two timing slots.
Like for example, when you
say, oh, I don't know, say.
cool lee or something like
this, you know, cool plus lee.
Or things like that, OK?
That where the phoneme
gets spread a given form
gets spread over two slots.
And things like or--
now syllable structure.
I think is that is imposed
on these timing slots.
And it is represented
on a plane that's is
orthogonal to the plane in which
the feature composition is.
And stress is yet on another
plane, which is orthogonal.
So that the axial, if you want
to have a physical picture,
it's like the knowledge
that you have of a word
is like a spiral bound notebook,
which is all, you know,
the registration is all in
terms of these timing slots.
And there's various structures
of the timing slots.
And you can peek.
I mean you can look from
one page to the other.
These pages, and so you
look at something here
and decide what to do
about the stress and so on.
And they have vast interesting,
specific properties.
And the syllable structure
is a particular kind
and I've written
about this and so
on but that's kind of a short
answer to a very long question.
Here.
AUDIENCE: There are
other experiments too.
You sort argue that
people represent
these phoneme representations
in sort of like motor control
program.
Not the acoustic signal isn't
important, per se, sort of more
try to map the acoustic
signal into a motor program
to recognize a phenome.
HALLE: Well I said
that there's something,
that there is
knowledge of language
use is independent of speaking.
Like for example,
it's conceivable
that you could be, if you
would have a let's say,
an injury or somebody
would have an injury.
And that would not permit
that person to speak.
Now some neurological
injury or simply block
any speaking of the person.
Would still know
English perfectly well.
Couldn't just, couldn't
perform the actions.
But the actions would
still be represented
by the language act.
And so in terms
of these features,
and the features are related
to accents, whether they
can be carried out or not.
AUDIENCE: I mean, people
have done experiments,
where you shoot
novocaine [INAUDIBLE]
using a different motor
sequence to produce [INAUDIBLE]..
HALLE: Yes and no.
Yes or no.
Yes to some extent too.
HALLE: But also, they never
make a T with their lips.
Or they never make a B
because they're abiding
by manipulating the velum.
I mean there is some plasticity.
But the elasticity
is very limited.
See, I mean, you're
absolutely right.
I mean, there is
this plasticity.
But the plasticity is--
AUDIENCE: But it seems like
they do those adjustments
based on acoustic information.
They try to produce--
HALLE: Look at
there's a real reason
why deaf people don't speak.
You know I mean, the
acoustics triggers it.
I mean, so, I said, I
didn't mean to say that.
We don't have to listen, if
you don't hear, you can't--
it never works, but there
is this very close tie
up between the acoustics
and the articulation.
And that's what I've
tried to stress.
AUDIENCE: But
internally you claim
you think or you say that you
believe words represented not
so much as a
sequence of features,
but more as the
sequence of actions.
HALLE: No.
But as the features are actions.
The features are actions.
They represent those features.
And the features
are actions which
have acoustic consequences.
And I don't want to--
I'm not for a moment
do I deny that.
PROFESSOR: Maybe we
better stop here.
HALLE: All right.
Thanks very much.
[APPLAUSE]